in the year 2000 it was announced that
we had developed the first draft of the
human genome which is a blueprint for
making human life the human proteome is
the next project that we are undertaking
biology and medicine are terribly
complicated and you have to use holistic
global approaches and those approaches
lead us to pioneer new types of
technologies and then we apply these to
fundamental problems in biology and more
recently in medicine proteomics is
important because proteins are the
molecular engines of life so we have to
understand proteins if we're to
understand biology there are about
20,000 different proteins in our body
and understanding the functions of all
of those proteins is the main goal of
the human proteome project the
challenges with the analysis of human
proteins are that it must be done by a
technique called mass spectrometry
wherein you cut the proteins into
smaller fragments that are called
peptides and you actually analyze the
peptides you add 20,000 proteins each of
which is cut into 50 peptides it has an
enormous computational problem we were
able to now access many more proteins
that what we could see in the past that
gave us large amounts of data than they
all needed to be catalog with all of
this information we'll be able to
interrogate the human and trying to
understand what's going on before
disease starts we have a computer
cluster here at ISP that allows us to
keep up with new datasets but we benefit
from processing all of the older data
that's been generated over and over
again with newer software and newer
reference proteome and that takes more
computational capacity than we have
sometimes somebody have big project or
they need to learn their job so I cannot
utilize
of course for area now I have 2400 calls
it's about five times more coarser than
we locally have it's easy to understand
as a simple code and modify it to fit my
need now that we've assembled all of
these mass spectrometry datasets
gathered from all around the world into
the Azure storage system the research
community can bring their own algorithms
and their own insights and apply it to
those data residing already in Azure the
impact of understanding the function of
all of these proteins will help us
understand and treat rare genetic
disorders as well as treats Alzheimer's
and type 1 diabetes that we still don't
have effective treatments for
you